[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour cette
émission spéciale grand débat diffusé à
la fois sur le réseau france bleu et sur
france 3 franche comté vos médias de
service public en région engagés au
service du débat public bonjour david
mal ensemble avec nos invités on va
évoquer dans la demi-heure à suivre
l'avenir de nos services publics en
région
bonjour jérémy chevreuil en effet
pendant une demi heure on va parler des
services publics dans la région franche
comté avec évidemment un focus sur la
santé sur les transports sur l'éducation
et en plateau avec nous et sur france
bleu et sur france 3 nous accueillons
michel antony bonjour bon logiciel
anthony vous êtes le président du comité
de vigilance pour le maintien des
services publics allure et à
luxeuil-les-bains bonjour à vous gilbert
bonjour bonjour vous êtes également avec
nous pendant cette demi heure vous êtes
le maire radical de salaire les bains
bonjour nous sommes également avec marc
paulin vous êtes infirmier au chu de
besançon où vous êtes blouse blanche
gilet jaune vous êtes également insoumis
et vous êtes syndicalistes à sud santé
au chu de besançon bonjour marc paulin
pour jour et bonjour eric alauzet vous
êtes le député de la majorité la
république en marche
élu du doubs bonjour eric alauzet
bonjour une première question
d'abord pour michel antony les gilets
jaunes ont beaucoup parlé d'injustice
sociale vous ça fait des années vous
vous battez pour le maintien des
services publics
ce que le mouvement des gilet jaune et
mais il reprend vos mots d'ordre vos
revendications d'après vous alors il
prend partiellement il représente en
tout cas en termes d'égalité
territoriales et en termes de jonction
avec l'égalité sociale il faut bien
comprendre ce que c'est que la la
disparition des services publics
c'est ce que j'appelle la double la
triple peine les gens perdent leurs
services publics les hôpitaux dans les
principaux services
les guichets de gare les trésoreries
certaines sections d'éducation dans
notre secteur sur l'urss est depuis 20
ans la norme quasiment tous les deux ans
les gens n'ont plus rien donc il ya une
désertification du secteur il ya une
difficulté d'y vivre
on est obligé de se déplacer comme les
transports publics dans le même temps ci
en déshérence sur un objet de prendre la
voiture
si on prend la voiture on allait les
frais de carburant on a les taxes
nouvelles on à cotia des autoroutes
vieux n'a pas trop chez nous on a les
péages en plus
on a forcément des amendes en dépassant
on allait perdre de temps on allait
perdre de chance comme disent les
médecins parce qu'elle risque sur la
route ça c'est la deuxième peine la
troisième c'est quand on arrive dans les
centres de regroupement est bien là
qu'est ce qu'on fait on est dans des
files d'attentes
on paye les parkings de plus en plus
dans les hôpitaux dans les autres lieux
et donc on n'arrête pas de payer est on
en train de désespérer les gens moi ce
qui m'inquiète dans aujourd'hui c'est
pas pourquoi il ya le mouvement du gilet
jaune c'est pourquoi elle n'a pas éclaté
plus tôt parce que là la désertification
elancourt depuis 30 ans aujourd'hui
les destructions de services son cours
depuis plus de 30 ans et on pousse de
plus en plus les gens à se regrouper
dans des grands centres oui ils n'en
peuvent mais où ils sont dans des
difficultés en plus de transports locaux
gilbert la situation décrite par michel
antony en haute saône elle est la même
dans le jura vous aussi vous êtes
confrontés à cette désertification
on a les mêmes problèmes à peu près
partout où j'aurais tendance à dire
qu'on a un état schizophrène qui nous
pousse à revitaliser nos territoires
ruraux en faisant des efforts pour faire
revenir du monde habité dans nos
campagnes un petit peu reculer et dans
le même temps et j'oserais dire en même
temps on nous supprime des services
publics mois la ville de salins la
trésorerie a fermé donc maintenant il
faut aller à poligny j'ai par exemple
mon centre thermal qui a des liquidités
avant vous pouvez les porter à la
perception
aujourd'hui il faut payer un
transporteur de transport de fonds ça
pèse sur les finances de la ville
et puis bon on va pas aussi se cacher il
ya un désengagement de l'état et qui
comptent sur les maisons des services au
public pour reprendre certaines missions
sans nous en donner les moyens
ça un combat l'intercommunalité ça un
coup qu'on ne peut pas toujours assumé
alors marc paulin vous êtes vous
infirmiers vous travaillez à l'hôpital
vous êtes blouse blanche et gilet jaune
là nos deux interlocuteurs et michel
anthony gilbert ont parlé manque de
services publics mais les gilet jaune
puisque vous en êtes ça n'est pas qu'une
revendication de service public il n'y a
pas que ça d'après vous ce n'est pas que
du service public toujours plus de
services publics répond que la question
du service public par les gilets jaunes
n'est pas directement posée et pourtant
dans les réclamations sait on de réclame
plus d'un de justice sociale et la
justice sociale peut être que c'est
justement plus de services publics plus
de services publics sur le territoire
comme la
l'expliqué michel antony où le maire de
sa main ça me paraît une évidence et
plus de services publics de compétences
dans les centres qui en font partie et
moi si je suis gilet jaune
si je suis blouse blanche et pour
dénoncer ça aujourd'hui on prend
conscience que les services publics ont
une utilité publique et l'utilité
sociale l'injustice sociale
elle peut être résolvez résout résolvez
oui pas résolu ce réseau par un service
public performant et aujourd'hui le
service public ne l'est plus notamment
les blouses blanches
d'où le collectif qui s'est créé deux
blouses blanches qui va du médecin
jusqu'à la tâche est encore aux aides à
domicile pour rejoindre les gilet jaune
depuis l'appel du 25
ce 25 janvier nous avons décidé
d'arrêter de nous plaindre de nos
services de subir skins pour nous n'a
plus de sens de fabriquer du soin à la
chaîne
alors que nous avons notre steam de nous
c'est de donner des soins de qualité
nous ne pouvons plus le faire et donc
nous avons appelé le 25 à rejoindre que
les blouses blanches mais une blouse
blanche qui n'est pas n'importe quel
blues
si vous la regardez bien c'est la blouse
d'opérer la chemise fendu que nous
remettons à nos clients quand ils
arrivent à l'hôpital pour leur signifier
qu'ils sont bien malades
eh bien nous nous la mettons car les
soignants les blouses blanches nous
avons le blues nous sommes malades et
nous avons décidé d'aller dans la rue
dire que nous soutenons et que nous
participons pleinement au mouvement des
gilets jaunes
eric alauzet vous êtes député de la
majorité vous avez entendu comme nous le
sombre tableau décrit par les trois
autres invités sur ce plateau avant la
crise des gilet jaune le gouvernement
avait déjà
engager la réflexion autour d'une rave
d'une réforme du service public
cent vingt mille suppressions de postes
de fonctionnaires d'ici la fin du mandat
c'est un objectif fixé par le président
de la république rappelait encore il ya
quelques jours par le secrétaire d'état
en charge de cette question olivier
dussopt est-ce qu'il faut maintenir cet
objectif
si vous me permettez d'aborder le sujet
un peu différemment
vous avez entendu les trois intervenants
qui traduisent assez bien ce qu'une
bonne partie de notre population
constate vie au quotidien donc une
insatisfaction concernant un service
public la santé l'école la police
et c est ce que nous trois cottagers
vous partagez le lendemain côté un pays
qui est parmi ceux au monde qui dépense
le plus pour sa fonction publique il ya
quand même un problème
peut-être qu'on a un problème
d'allocation c'est-à-dire d'orientation
de la petite dépense publique qui n'est
peut-être pas tout à fait pertinents
autrement dit on a quand même gonflé et
gonflé je vais faire un petit peu
saint-pardon l'administration centrale
et au bout de la chaîne au contact du
public
les aides soignants les infirmiers dans
les hôpitaux les enseignants dans les
stades et dans les établissements
d'enseignement les policiers au contact
de la population ou là effectivement on
a parfois réduits ou encombrer nos ses
salariés de tâche peut-être qu'il
n'était pas central donc il faut pas
juste raisonner en plus ou moins de
fonctionnaires c'est le fonctionnaire ou
le service public en général le service
public service au public au bon endroit
et je crois qu'il faut maintenant
regarder la réalité la réalité en face
moi j'ai consacré mon rapport puisque le
rapporteur pour avis la sécurité sociale
auditionné beaucoup d'infirmiers et
d'aides-soignants à 7h connais
professionnellement je suis confronté
donc je connais assez bien la situation
notamment celui des aides-soignantes
dans les ehpad ou véritablement il ya
une insuffisance alors de fonctionnaires
c'est pas que du privé il ya du public
il ya du privé aussi donc c'est une
question de l'allocation de la direction
dans laquelle on utilise en flèche
l'argent public pour aller au coeur près
des gens se rappellent le front-office
peut-être il faut faire d'histoires sur
le back office sur l'arrière sur une
initiation l'administration centrale
mais faire des efforts au contact du
public
50 le milieu rural bien entendu sur les
différents services mais aussi les
fonctions publiques centrales dans les
capitales comme le ch est pour pour
l'hôpital alors eric alauzet vous êtes
députés d'une majorité qui dit il faut
pas nécessairement plus de
fonctionnaires pas plus de services
publics mais un meilleur service public
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de nous
dire là on est sur france bleu et sur
france 3 on est entre nous en franche
comté
gilbert est ce que vous êtes en capacité
d'entendre ça il faut pas plus de
services publics mais un meilleur
service public
je suis tout à fait capable d'entendre
qu'il faut un meilleur service public à
condition qu'on parte des besoins du
terrain et qu'on ne soit pas
malheureusement tributaire de décisions
prises par des technocrates à paris qui
ne viennent jamais nous voir sur le
terrain et qui ne prennent pas forcément
en compte les réels besoins du terrain
est ce que c'est pas une critique facile
simpliste qu'on entend partout en france
ça c'est la faute aux technocrates
technocrates parisiens
non je pense que c'est pas simpliste
quand on a par exemple je vais prendre
l'exemple du lycée de salins une filière
c'est très bien de vouloir spécialisés
les lycées mais ce qui est encore en
cours pour la rentrée prochaine c'est
très bien de vouloir spécialisés mais
vous êtes à paris
vous faites une filière au lycée henri
iv et une autre au lycée louis-le-grand
il ya 150 mètres d'écart nous la même
chose c'est 50 km comment est ce qu'on
peut faire la même réforme à paris à
lyon ou à marseille et l'appliquer dans
un territoire qui n'a pas la même
densité qui n'a pas les mêmes moyens de
transport ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
pris en compte la ruralité dans les
décisions et on ne peut pas faire des
décisions une appliquer des décisions
uniforme partout de la même façon
michel antony est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce que vous vous considérez
être un meilleur service public je
rappelle que vous venez d'une ville où
on a manifesté pour garder une prison ce
qui est assez étonnant les gens qui ne
connaissent pas la situation locale ça
les surprend toujours
mais voilà allure les gens sont sortis
dans la rue pour demander le maintien
d'une prison le débat il est simple
c'est partir des besoins
qu est ce qu ont besoin les gens ils ont
besoin d'avoir deux une présence des
collectivités territoriales ou de l'état
leur service nos qu'il faut maintenir ce
dont ils ont besoin ils ont pas envie de
se dépasser en permanence et quand on
est attaqué
la prison de lure comme madame taubira
nous a fait le plaisir de venir sur lui
elle était stupéfaite justement de la
manifestation qu'on avait organisé avec
le comité des gens qui se battent pour
une prison pourquoi parce que les gens
très bien compris que c'est pas
l'enfermement pour lesquelles on se
battait mais c'était le dernier service
public qui est resté digne de ce nom
dans le secteur et c'était plus qu'un
symbole et si on doit partir des
services publics par rapport à ce que
disait monsieur alauzet ça fait en temps
quand même que le gouvernement nous dise
ça que c'est un problème de gestion que
c'est un problème d'organisation
or on a supprimé on a taillé dans le vif
en permanence on a taillé dans le vif en
permanence matin on n'a pas tenu compte
du démocratie locale
la démocratie par exemple c'est nos amis
de saint claude qui donne de l'amener il
avec le référendum à propos de leur
maternité
ils ont touché quand même une trentaine
de communautés qui sont tous ceux qui se
déplaçait sur evra 19% pour le maintien
de la maternité comme on a fait le
référendum allure qui est à l'origine de
la création de la coordination de de
défense des hôpitaux et maternités de
proximité avec cette afrique à l'époque
on avait amené presque quinze mille
personnes n'ont même plus la moitié du
corps inscrits 99% des gens voulaient
des urgences et aux montants michel
anthony n'en tiens pas ya la moitié des
français qui veulent qu'on réduise le
nombre de fonctionnaires mais je parle
pas de fonctionnaires là moi je parle
d'un service après après si vous voulez
que tout ça c'est un argument qui est
père facile on n'est pas là pour
débattre sur des statistiques aux nappes
pour débattre sur des besoins
après c'est aux élus puisqu'ils sont
charge de trouver les moyens de faire au
mieux pour eux pour y subvenir
mais il faut pas d'abord gérer la
pénurie puis dire oh là là on a plus
assez de
quand on a été voir le responsable
aération liban oui nous manque son de
chants de chose de gentil ce nous
forcément les urgences de nuire à les
fermer partout et ce mur haut valais
fermés partout et plus on va réduire d
urgence et on va laisser dans la misère
est dans la déshérence les gens degrés
les gens légende de saint claude où les
gens de lure sur le problème quoi ça
c'est pas acceptable parce que c'est un
un débat de type politique qu'on entend
depuis 30 ans aujourd'hui et je pense
que le ras-le-bol des gilet jaune
aujourd'hui s'exprime c'est aussi par
rapport à ça gilbert vous qui êtes mère
de salah on est sur france bleu et sur
france 3 vous avez l'habitude de dire
nous les petites villes ont fait ou on
se bat on essaye de maintenir des
services attractifs pour être justement
une petite ville qui peut résister dans
le grand monde des métropoles est ce que
vous partagez la vie de michel antony
dire on a organisé cette désertification
deux choses la première
je pense qu'on a des fonctionnaires de
grande qualité que ce soit dans la
fonction publique territoriale ou dans
la fonction publique hospitalière
moi je leur rends hommage donc l'image
du fonctionnaire qui est là qui regarde
sa montre
c'est pas que c'est pas vrai partout la
deuxième chose qu'il faut quand même
dire que pour nous les villes on a quand
même subi une baisse des dotations
globales de fonctionnement depuis quatre
ans sévère on est à l'os là on a fait
quand même des efforts on ne représente
que 10% de la dette les plaies les
petites les petites villes comme nous on
a fait sur le bloc communal 14 milliards
d'économies en quatre ans qui ont été
effacées en une journée
puisqu'on a lâché 10 milliards pour
calmer l'agitation sociale
alors moi de mon côté je me dis quatre
ans d'efforts pour être ruinée en une
seule journée
où est la cohérence budgétaire alors
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les villes
comme ça l'un on est obligé de pallier
bien entendu ou autant qu'on peut mais
il ya un moment je vous le répète nos
budgets sont à loos eric alauzet que
répondez vous à votre voisin qui gère
une administration se précise vous êtes
aussi élu municipal à besançon vous
connaissez aussi ces problématiques de
budgets municipaux
effectivement les mères dans leur très
grande majorité se plaignent de faire
d'immenses efforts
avec peu de retours et beaucoup de
pression de l'état tout le monde a été
mis à contribution les collectivité
locales l'ont été les administrations
des administrations de la sécurité six
milliards c'est un cas là la ponction
sur les sur les communes s'est passé pas
14 mia et ça s'est arrêté vous le savez
cette année hormis pour les grandes
villes acquis auquel on continue à
demander un effort pour les 316 8 donc
un effort a tellement et à tout le monde
à la sécurité sociale également à l'état
c'est l'état qui va faire les plus gros
efforts dans l'est dans les années qui
viennent maintenant après avoir
effectivement sollicité beaucoup les
collectivités locales
mais j'étais ce matin avec un artisan
qui venait de montrer les feuilles de
paye de ses salariés faye salaire net de
ces boulangers 1400 euros
ça lui coûte 3000 2900 euros donc quand
vous disiez les français veulent qu'on
réduise le nombre de fonctionnaires a et
français effectivement il ya eu la
question des impôts des taxes et y
regarde comment éventuellement les
dépenses publiques et pas que les
dépenses publiques pourraient peser
moins sur leur but il est très
majoritairement les français pensent que
l'argent des impôts est mal utilisé
alors voilà donc je vous disais tout à
l'heure qu'il fallait sans doute
recentrer l'activité sur le front office
au contact du public et aussi des
économies à faire
moi qui suis médecin je peux vous dire
que les examens redondants en médecine
qu'on répète et qu'on répète parce que
le dossier médical partagé n'existe pas
encore il n'ya pas y'a pas de suivi que
les examens inutiles
aussi c'est une c'est une dépense qui
nous qui ne pénaliserait personne bien
au contraire parce qu'en plus on crée de
la iatrogénie cité srd et parfois quand
on est hospitalisé trop longtemps on
peut avoir des effets liés à
l'hospitalisation sans doute eric allodi
colloque et là on perd on pourrait dire
également que si les gens font des
émules aux examens c'est parce qu'ils
ont attendu pendant des mois et non non
non non non non non pas du tout c'est
parce qu'il ya pas de parcours de soins
qui a pas de suivi à travers un dossier
médical
je vous assure j'ai travaillé de
paiement cds des années ces questions on
a beaucoup beaucoup d'économies est revu
et georgina pénalise pas les gens si si
qui ne panassié ya des économies à faire
dans le monde de la santé
je serai moi je ne suis pas pour qu'on
dépense à tout va mais parallèlement
j'aimerais bien qu'on rémunère à plein
va les gens qui donnent d'eux-mêmes pour
faire fonctionner parce que c'est eux
qui fonctionne qui font qu'ils sont
largement au dessus de leurs voeux plus
de personnel d'affinion moi c'est
d'ailleurs qui travaillent à 1200 euros
sequana excuses aux personnes qui ont
acquis le matin vous vous donnez le
petit déjeuner vous demande si vous
voulez un un pain avec du beurre la
confiture de fraises à beaune en battant
et je vais aller chercher la confiture
de myrtille parce que vous préférez la
confiture de myrtilles ce sont ces
gens-là ensuite qu'ils vont aller dans
les chambres pour entretenir les locaux
un ballet y est c'est dès qu'il ya un
petit problème c'est eux qu'on appelle
ils sont corvéables à merci parce que
maintenant on les déplace de service en
service ces gens là ils gagnent en début
de carrière ils sont tous contractuels
maintenant quasiment donc largement
corvéable 1200 euros n'est d'accord
s'ils n'ont pas à l'aide de leur
employeur pour payer la moitié de la
mutuelle puisque maintenant il faut une
mutuelle
ces gens là sont des travailleurs
pauvres ils sont dans la rue et il faut
sinon concret moi je suis surpris de
voir des collègues qui sont comme ça
donc faire des économies j'étais à un
moment c'est sûr qu'on avait parlé
d'argent
moi je dis le mouvement des gilets
jaunes il a omis au moins eu un mérite
assez grandiose à mes yeux c'est qu'il a
remis en perspective les discours que
vous avez pour réclamer quelques petites
sommes
alors que on dépense où on ne va pas
chercher l'argent qui est évadé fiscal
mans on parle de 100 milliards d'euros
eh oui monsieur lozès et sans remise en
cause les choix c'est qu on a ça vous
avez doublé le cice de 20 à 40 je tenais
l'évasion fiscale que ce sont les
chevreuils dans sa devise qui débauchent
les autoroutes moins 6000 emplois et
touchent des dizaines de milliards
d'euros
carrefour exactement pareil donc
l'argent aux caisses et asus eee mais ce
n'est pas le principal parce que
l'argent il y en a
le souci c'est peut-être de se reposer
la question philosophiquement
qu'est ce que c'est que le service
public pour la santé moi je vous le dit
claire et nette
mais quelle plus grande injustice de
devoir de ne pas être égaux devant la
maladie
et bien aujourd'hui en 2019 monsieur
lozès
avec les politiques qui ont été menées
deux ministres ministres nous ne sommes
plus égaux devant la maladie
nous ne sommes plus égaux devant la
maladie et nous n'y sommes plus encore
plus maintenant avec des mutuelles que
nous devons payer que nous devons
peut-être même additionnées il nous faut
deux mutuelles trois mutuelles mais
comment on fait dans le futur on va
s'arrêter ou mary ann aux dépenses
beaucoup dépend cotisent beaucoup on y
pense ma france là où il est
alors pour la sens justement pour
recentrer eric alauzet dit eric alauzet
une réflexion qui va un peu dans le sens
de marc paulin parce que c'est aussi un
sentiment largement partagé une
réflexion d'eric les grandes entreprises
paient très peu d'impôts il y à la
fraude fiscale l'optimisation fiscale
les niches fiscales le cic eux il faut
il faut arrêter de prendre les français
pour des imbéciles
est ce que enfin comment répondre à ce
sentiment encore une fois largement
partagée qu'on me demande des efforts qu
à certains je connais particulièrement
le sujet d'évasion fiscale j'ai passé
tout mon mandat à travailler sur ce
sujet là je sais quels progrès ont été
faits je sais les progrès qui restent à
faire il ya sans doute pas 100 milliards
comme c'est une facilité un de dire 5
milliards parce que comme l évasion la
grèce on claque des 200 milliards il ya
plus de dettes aux finances tout
l'hôpital l'école et non c'est pas ça la
réalité
la france est en pointe est un des pays
les plus en pointe l'europe avance parce
que les états ils ont peur aussi
ils sentent bien ce mouvement de
poujadisme d'extrême droite qui arrive
articulations dans les bars jadis à
dénoncer et erika l'énergie et loïc
comme disait marc bolland qui reposait
cette quête du gardien pour la cité et
on attend bruno le maire sans parler
d'une taxe sur les gaffes ah oui on sent
bien que le ministre dit il ya un sujet
là alors quand bien même quand bien même
avant les députés pouvaient travailler
sur cette question et on sent que il ya
cette volonté de redonner quand même un
sens oui montre juste il s'est assez la
millions ça c'est la grande sur les gars
c'est la france qui en point je rigole
par rapport à ce qu'ils gagnent et ce
qu'ils ont fraudé c'est la fessée en
pointe sur ce sujet il faut l'unanimité
en europe pour prendre une telle
décision il ya quatre pays est toujours
les mêmes
l'irlande le luxembourg chypre qui
veulent pas y aller mais c'est la france
qui est en point allait il nous fait
comprendre ce qu'elle pense mais plus
pour sa santé
l'une est au coeur du sujet mais à
l'arrivée c'est tout et on attend ajouté
on est sur france bleu est sur france 3
nous sommes avec michel antony président
du comité de vigilance pour le maintien
de services publics avec gilbert maire
de st avec marc paulin infirmiers au chu
de besançon et avec eric alauzet député
de la république en marche gilbert vous
dites ça me fait doucement rire quand
j'entends le ministre dire on va aller
chercher 500 millions d'euros chez les
gars fort mais quand vous regardez le
chiffre d'affaires des gaffes à et qu'
ils prennent 500 millions c'est quoi ces
trois minutes de leur chiffre d'affaires
journalier on plaisante là c'est très
bien de le faire mais c'était
plaisanterie 500 millions je crois je
crois qu'il faut quand même reposer le
débat parce que là on est en train de
parler
comment on fait pour faire des économies
moi je pense j'aurais plutôt tendance à
dire comment est ce qu'on s'en sort de
tout ça comment est-ce qu'on récupère de
l'argent pour que nos services publics
fonctionnent le problème essentiel c'est
la dette colossale de l'état français
moi en tant que maire demain je présente
un budget en déséquilibre
je suis mis sous la tutelle de l'état
qui lui se permet des déficits
budgétaires chaque année ça veut dire
que le c'est comme si à l'école
le dernier de la classe contrôler et
corrigé le bon élève il ya un moment il
faut que faut que ça s'arrête donc il
faut regarder qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant
financièrement vous avez un homme qui
s'appelait antoine pinay quand il est
arrivé en 58
qu'est ce qu'il a fait mais il a lancé
un grand emprunt national
vous avez un pays qui s'appelle le japon
je pense que vous connaissez ça monsieur
à l'oseille tient un déficit budgétaire
bien supérieur à celui de la france et
qu'il n'a aucun problème
tout simplement parce que la dette des
japonais appartient aux japonais tout
simplement
et ils n'ont pas de problème de marchés
extérieurs de taux d'intérêt qui montent
et qui nous fait payer des loyers
légèrement différent
michel
anthony sûr il faut faire il faut
prioriser les services publics
j'aimerais qu'on y revienne pas recentré
le débat
voilà on n'est pas là pour débattre des
finances et de chats c'est des problèmes
cruciaux mais c'est pas nous les
résoudre par contre les exigences à nous
de les poser et aujourd'hui ou ancien
grand débat c'est très bien la
démocratie ou à la vérifier et puis on
continue à fermer les services publics
c'est à dire que vous faut-il sans les
financer je suis d'accord mais par
contre pour le moment il ya quelque
chose qui était vicié 6,92 débattre sur
ce qu'on va faire et coco ténu les
destructions qui sont en cours
là il ya une responsabilité des agents
de l'état qui est dramatique parce que
c'est se moquer du monde
les gens de saint claude pour les
maternités les gens de des trésoreries
dans tous les coins du secteur les
tribunaux qui sont menacées qui est en
grève récemment on continue à détruire
ça donc si on dit parlons des services
publics tant le ciel subi qui exigent un
moratoire sur ce qui se passe c'est
d'ailleurs ce que lance l'association
des maires ruraux de france
mais et c'est là notamment dans les
revendications des gilet jaune un
paradoxe a demandé moins de pression
fiscale et plus de service public
jacques paul je pense moi que les gilets
jaunes repose finalement le sens de
notre société comment allons-nous vivre
ensemble pouvons nous supporter encore
longtemps le reportage de là la dame qui
vit avec ses 512 euros que vous avez
fait vos collègues de dijon mais qui est
du québec n'a diffusé aussi intéressant
c'est que c'est pas possible
et c'est chez nous c'est des gens et on
en a tous comme ça dans leur famille
mais comment c'est possible que ça reste
comme ça
heureusement que les gilet jaune se sont
mobilisés et moi j'appelle la population
à se mobiliser aux blouses blanches de
se mobiliser parce que c'est
insupportable
nous pouvons faire autrement et nous
reposons la question de comment
allons-nous le faire je pense que les
services publics les services au public
pour baisser les inégalités entre les
individus par rapport à leur niveau
social ou leur lieu d'habitation et bien
c'est ça le service public revenons un
petit peu de sens dans tout ça et les
gilets jaunes finalement avec tout leur
non sens toutes leurs
difficulté à se construire et c'est
finalement nous recentre sur le
principal et je pense que les services
publics nous sommes la base de deux qui
va unir tout ça et il faut vraiment se
battre et la santé c'est peut-être
l'élément fort et nous on réclame aussi
le 100% sécu en terminer avec le chacun
pour soi chacun sa mutuelle et chacun sa
propre capacité à affronter les maladies
ou les accidents de la vie mais non
c'est à la collectivité de prendre en
charge ces maladies tel que l'avait
défini en 45 les précurseurs de la
sécurité sociale et vous êtes sur france
bleu et sur françois il nous reste deux
minutes ça fait trente secondes chacun
la question que se pose évidemment tous
les français c'est comment va sortir de
cette grande incertitude de ce grand
mouvement des gilet jaune comme on doit
s'en sortir d'après vous eric alauzet et
en 30 secondes
c'est au cas par cas il faut discuter la
santé j'ai donné quelques pistes plus de
moyens aux personnels pour accompagner
les gens mieux rémunérés si on le peut
et mois de dépenses inutiles des examens
redondants parfois dangereux par exemple
sur sur l'école là aussi il faut
regarder si on peut faire des économies
sur l'administration centrale pour avoir
des enseignants auprès de nos de nos
enfants dans la campagne et le milieu
rural
le guichet ça compte et donc peut-être
il ya des économies à faire ailleurs
on a le pays qui a la dépense publique
la plus élevée malgré l'évasion fiscale
et sert à l'évasion fiscale c'est pas ça
qui paie la sécurité sociale das cruzes
social c'est que les cotisations
salariales bien donc on cotise beaucoup
mon boulanger tout à l'heure si vous lui
demander de cotiser plus il peut plus il
asphyxie
gilbert il faut être raisonnable et
faire des économies là on peut en fait
en quelques secondes comment vous pensez
qu'on peut sortir de ce grand mouvement
je pense que le grand débat va
certainement amené des pistes je pense
qu'il faut surtout que l'état renouent
avec les élus de terrain que nous sommes
et nous redonne les moyens d être des
amortisseurs sociaux
je vous disais ce matin j'ai pas pu moi
m 5000 euros pour envoyer des enfants en
vacances cet été
parce que mon budget ne le permet pas eh
ben peut-être que si on nous donnait un
petit peu plus de moyens qu'on nous
rendait les moyens qu'on nous a pris eh
ben je pense que là il y aura peut-être
pas eu ce mouvement d gilet jaune
on n'aura pas le temps de finir le
dernier tour d'abc désolé il faut qu'on
robe dentelle
merci à tous les quatre merci david
d'avoir participé tous ensemble à cette
émission sur france 3 et sur le réseau
france bleu merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission spéciale profitez bien de votre
après midi à bientôt sur vos médias de
service public en région
[Musique]